tous les matins je suis pas d'accord
vous verront gagné par mois thomas
voeckler ça dépend en fait tout dépend
parce que ça dépendrait de pau ce que
j'ai ça dépend si j'achète entrevoir si
on réponse à la question qu'est ce que
tu veux faire quand tu seras grand votre
enfant vous réponds influenceurs ne
l'emmenez pas tout de suite chez le psy
car montrer ses abdos et prendre en
photo son petit déjeuner pourrait le
rendre riche depuis quelques années les
candidats issus de la téléréalité qui
sont devenus influenceurs ont pris une
place prédominante sur les réseaux on
vient d'arriver à tous vas y mon
aspirateur à prenois résorbant le code
promo à coups de promotion de produits
de voyages sponsorisés et de codes promo
ses vedettes 2.0 même la vie de rêve
pendant que vous vous vous usez le
pousse à liker leurs publications pour
se valoriser en tant qu influenceurs à
chacun sa méthode
il y a ceux qui communiquent en couple
comme jessica et thibault qui n'hésite
pas à tous livrés à leurs followers
comme le débrief à chaud de la naissance
compliqué de leur enfant est enfin
récompensé d'avoir tant attendu n'avoir
pas stresser en
jazz et laurent aussi font tout à 2 une
stratégie qui rapporte puisqu'il ya eu
deux leur communauté représente 4,1
millions de followers de quoi générer de
gros partenariats dont chaque poste pour
apporter entre cinq et vingt mille euros
ah tiens même chose pour nabila qui à
elle seule représente 5 millions de
followers une fanbase qui en fait l'une
des reines du secteur globalement les
filles sont plus suivi que les hommes le
mari de nabila thomas vergara ne compte
que 1,5 million d'abonnés
ces trois points 5 millions de moins que
son épouse même chose pour laurent qui
compte 400 mille abonnés de moins que le
jazz et quand on n'a pas d'enfant a
présenté certains influenceurs n'hésite
pas à mettre tous leurs atouts en avant
pour motiver leur fanbase quitte à
oublier quelques vêtements dans la salle
de bains ou death
mais si ces chiffres semblent
hallucinant on est encore loin des stars
us à titre d'exemple selena gomez
empocherait grâce à ces 161 millions
d'abonnés 550 mille dollars pour un seul
poste sur instagram ça donne envie de
s'y mettre
[Applaudissements]
tu as plus de 2 millions de fans sur
instagram
c'est assez fascinant vrai vrai vrai
vrai vrais influenceurs j'ai demandé
jeudi à la vérité on a demandé à mme
agrebi berda ce que forcément c'est là
c'est la papesse j'ai à dire la madame
claude
je retiens pas non ça veut dire chef ça
me dit tu peux dire à tous
bon bah c'est mieux mais je retire c'est
tout ce que j'ai pour les la papesse je
lui dis tu peux recevoir vraiment ce
qu'ils vendent bill ratez pas une motion
à la dernière il ya un garçon tout dur
qui venait vous est tout excité là une
très jolie fille elle est magnifique
ah bah oui mais quand même génial c'est
qu'il joue dit on est pendus j'avais dit
que c'était une blague pour et donc je
vais dès qu'ils ont peut recevoir
vraiment quelqu'un des grands grands
influenceurs tu menaces i t3 et parmi
les trois avaient mis là et tu as
accepté de venir aujourd'hui et c'est
très gentil parce que la semaine
dernière rémi nota est venue il ya quand
même rien à faire dès qu'on parle de ce
métier dès qu'on parle de vous de votre
métier parce que c'est un métier il faut
le dire aujourd'hui c'est pour ça qu'on
est là c'est pas pour se moquer de vous
eh ben ça part dans tous les sens aspect
dernière way 6000 euros pour rémy nota
et tout ça il faut que ça rentre dans la
tête des gens aujourd'hui les grands
groupes comme publicis et tout ça c'est
fini le monde a évolué et aujourd'hui ce
sont ces gens là personnalité dit qu' on
vous comprend pourquoi qui font qu'ils
vont vendre de la pub
donc voilà donc donc mis là tu as deux
millions de de d'instagram heures
aujourd'hui
en un mot qu'est ce qui fait son succès
qu'est ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui à ton
avis tu es l'une des plus grandes
installera me semble des plus grandes
influences eux mêmes questions combien
merci
après qu'est-ce qu'il ya un secret est
ce qu'il ya une clé ça je sais pas je
pense que info est assez constant sur
les réseaux sociaux je pense qu'il faut
aussi donner à son public c'est à dire
comment là bas je suis sur télé réalité
donc c'est un autre concept encore j'ai
une chaîne youtube
donc ces deux choses qui sont
complètement différentes mais j'ai
accepté en fait de d'exposer toute ma
vie sur les réseaux sociaux
et je pense que c'est pour ça aussi la
vie ça veut dire les photos sexy aussi
ça marche plus on est honnête bah ouais
enfin moi personnellement si tu regardes
ont enfin si tu regarde mon instagram
il n'y a pas de faim je pense que j'ai
plus de j'aime pour des photos où je
suis complètement naturelle depuis que
j'ai fait me dire on a vu dans une
émission où j'ai fait de la survie et
alors tu vois ben voilà le carton j'ai
eu plus de l'oeil sur le carton que sur
cette photo donc après je pense que ça
dépend appelez moi et toi pourquoi toi
parce que parce que parce que parce que
tu as créé un personnage j'aimerais tout
d'abord c'est la télé réalité on va pas
se mentir parce que c'est quand même ça
c'est c'est quelque chose qui nous donne
de la visibilité je pense pas que si
j'avais fait si je n'avais pas fait télé
réalité aujourd'hui j'aurais eu autant
de succès je sais pas façon part dans le
passé maintenant je pense que la télé
réalité ça m'a aidé mais c'est pas tout
ça veut dire que la télé réalité ça te
donne une visibilité de la lumière
mais si on suit ses pas t'en servir à sa
part c'est comme toute chose j'ai une
chaîne youtube
j'ai aussi des marques que j'ai créée
ben je collabore aussi avec d'autres
marques
j'avais une émission à moi qui
s'appelait sos me l'a donc c'est quelque
chose que je travaille oui monsieur
moi je suis désolé il ya des choses qui
me gêne pas spécialement est ce que vous
avez dit vous me l'avez dit vous mathieu
oui parce que vous dites c'est fini le
temps de publicis maintenance non mais
pas du tout pas du tout il y a
effectivement tu t'occupes très bien un
magali des gens qui sont issus la
téléréalité ce que vous avez rappelé qui
devient influenceurs s'agit rien très
bien mais ça représente une toute petite
partie de ce que sont les influences et
ses influences heure là les plus
importants qui sont sur le secteur haut
de gamme - copuler ou voix et luxe il
fonctionne toujours par des grandes
agences de pub il ya deux personnes et
caroline receveur qui fonctionne très
bien sur un cpu
vous avez une autre qui s'appelle jeanne
damas qui la ligue 2 complète sur tout
ce qui est de gamme qui vient de même
d'ouvrir un restaurant et ces gens là
existe ça représente 95% des ménages
la réalité représente une petite marque
partie du marché ces commissions alors
que je suis papa julien lepers susana
vera mahmoudi non mais excusez moi enfin
je me permets moi j'ai beaucoup de
respect pour carolyn rogers mais de base
elle vient de là-bas sur calvin la télé
réalité alors aujourd'hui elle a réussi
à faire autre chose son image et c'est
tout à son honneur mais là pas elle a
enchaîné les télé réalité comme vous
pouvez fermer ma g
je suis content d une chaîne youtube à
moitié qui me l'a dit c'est vrai mais tu
es aujourd'hui elle va continuer je suis
pas d'accord puis je suis pas d'accord
avec vous passez dans le sens où
aujourd'hui on a je ne sais combien
téléspectateurs qui nous regardent tous
les soirs donc on a un autre public qui
nous suit le dépenser pour s'arrêter
quand tu vas arrêter les téléréalités tu
penses que tu broies continue cependant
je pense pas tu vois pas ce que regarde
j'ai stoppé pendant un an et ma chaîne
youtube a cartonné
elle souhaite mais là ça car oui c'est
effectivement pendant un an aujourd'hui
les annonceurs ne veulent plus de
maquereaux influenceurs ses affluents se
reprenne en main à quelqu'un qui a
beaucoup beaucoup de followers cherche
des micros influenceurs données par mois
ça dépend en fait tout dépend parce que
ça dépend de deux postes que j'ai ça
dépense entre 20 et 50 mille euros voyez
alala souayah commence comme ça d'un go
mois
c'est extrêmement neige se dire en tant
que produit de wever mais un chiffre
d'affaires mais quand on a dit non mais
on a gagné un chiffre d'affaires il n'y
a pas beaucoup de frais les marchés
saluent pas tout à fait p oui alors
effectivement je gagne ma vie
aujourd'hui que dans mon travail
précédent va pas se mentir on va pas
être ingrat c'est la vérité quoi avant
tout
j'étais danseuse oui donc ses danseuses
c'est pas le même métier maintenant en
toute honnêteté j'ai une société on est
en france je pense qu'on est tous
déclaré on sait quoi voilà je vous quand
par exemple on ne paye 10 mille euros
c'est pas dix mille euros
non mais ça va pas du tout d un pour moi
ce matin un nouveau teaser mais pour les
gens aux plantes cinquante mille euros
pense que c'est dans notre poche
j'aurais aimé que vous avez dit c'est
que vous vous avouez vous ne savez pas
pourquoi vous plaisait plus que les
autres ce qui pour moi est le début
peut-elle va pas signer la fin de vos
deux de vos de votre business un jour
c'est non pas du tout monsieur lagacé
dans votre spécificité
moi je ne le connaissais pas bravo doré
moi je suis très heureuse trois jeunes
femmes qui réussissent bravo non moi
quand je vous ai vu sur votre instagram
c'est générationnel donc pardon ce
physicien un clone de kim kardashian et
j'ai l'impression que finalement
apparaître ça non mais je suis ça sera
quand vous ou alors alors déjà je suis
moi même
en plus de ça j'ai une chaîne youtube et
comme je vous disais j'avais entre delhi
fois mais ne l'avait pas entendu ce que
vous parlez c'est instagram donc moi je
vous le dire j'ai une chaîne youtube où
justement je donne des conseils aux
jeunes femmes je me permets de donner
des conseils parce que je ressens
moi je suis pas quelqu'un de prétentieux
je vais pas venir en dix ans alors moi
je suis bien placée pour donner des
conseils pour faire 6 pour faire ça
parce que en vrai oui je suis connue bas
je suis connue parce que peut-être que
les gens m'aiment bien peut-être
qu'aujourd'hui j'ai une certaine
notoriété et je ne sais pas vous dire
pourquoi mais effectivement oui eh ben
je fais des tutos de maquillage
voilà je fais des tutos de maquillage je
donne également des conseils aux jeunes
femmes c'est peut-être pour ça que c'est
clair on apprend des trucs ont suivi sur
snapshot déjà on suit aujourd'hui les
influenceurs la majorité c'est sur les
réseaux sociaux et sur les story c'est
pas sur les photos instagram et
effectivement ils sont suivis ils voient
leur quotidien et sert haquin qui a rien
à dire qui a rien à donner ou qui n'est
pas vraiment comment dire qu'ils aient
lambda effet qu' on ne va pas intéresser
si les gens aiment il a aussi les gens
aiment jessica ou nabila c'est parce que
sur snat
il donne des choses ils montrent leur
personnalité et que leur personnalité
c'est que les champs mais là je
comprends que ça existe ou pas je vois
des petits mecs et tout ça que j'ai
jamais vue de ma vie qui ont 40 50 60 80
mineurs
est ce que oui ou pas on peut acheter ou
ça peut très us à peu ce truc et pour
avoir des bien sûr ça s'achète défaut
alors bien sûr sauf que c'est ce que je
dis moi au candidat quand je les reçois
les nouveaux jadue fait attention ça ne
tiendra pas sur le long terme y aller
parce qu'une magazine vous fait poster
dunk vous donner un code promo donc la
marque s exactement combien vous ramener
à la marque elle sait combien vous payer
combien vous paye et combien vous lui
fait gagner
donc si en fait vous avez en milieu
polaire et que vous avez vendu deux
produits j'en sors ça qu'il faut en tout
cas c'était hyper hyper hyper courage de
donner tous ces montants et j'ai vu des
conseils à jean gitane guillaume et j'ai
dit [ __ ] mais c'est j'aime bien ce que
tu es des aides et conseils
j'ai des bons conseils je trouve
formidable longue vie à toi merci
[Musique]